hey John my name is not Hank who the eff
is Hank well to that I say clean up your
language young person or old person or
middle person no my name is Craig aka
wheezy waiter on the intertubes that's
right if you ever see me on a lazy river
riding an inter tube call me wheezy
waiter a few years ago I filled in for
you John and I did my best impression of
you that I could it was well received
Roger Ebert of the Chicago sun-times
said two thumbs up several times
throughout his career about other things
anyway if any of you nerdfighters miss
Hank right now I will do some things
that Hank does dancing should do a lot
of hip thrusts we need me hit dance like
Hank he also sings rock music rock music
yeah what else does he do
breathing pooping I'm assuming yeah and
other stuff
he also smiles when he talks that mean
talks like this sometimes when he's
trying to get his words out you know
what I'm talking about John so all bad
impressions aside right now we are
celebrating pizza mess in honor of me
trying to be like Hank I'm going to tell
you about the science of pizza the term
pizza first appeared in a Latin text
around the 10th century in southern
Italy here's a reenactment it's a
calling to pizza I learned everything
about my Italian accent from Mario 64
mythical the Latin text was found in the
town of Gaeta Italy and it stated that a
person of a certain property is to give
the Bishop of Gaeta 12 pizzas every day
basically you have to give 12 pizzas to
the bishop if you are at a certain high
income level or upper crust if you will
I'm sorry
I'm sorry also I just realized I'm
talking about the history of pizza and
not the science of pizza history is more
your thing John I'm sorry here's the
science of pizza and it's achill that's
the last time I'll do the most basic
pizzas have three things well four if
you can't enjoy five if you come
bloating when you eat too much but the
three are bread sauce cheese why did I
have to look at that I've had pizza
before the bread is made of flour water
and baker's yeast which is actually a
living single-celled fungus called
Saccharomyces cerevisiae yeah I said a
big word that means I got to the science
boom science - moving on and of course a
crucial element of pizza John is the
pizza John mustache so here's the
history of the mustache the oldest
portrait of a mustache is an Iranian
Horseman from 300 AD BC BC not 80 BC I
couldn't find the photo but I imagine it
looks something like this by horse mane
I assume they meant centaur and by photo
I threw pies when they met sewn to a
pillow that is all I have for you today
I assume you learned nothing
Thank You Hank and John for having me I
love doing these please have lots more
kids I'll see you sometime
[Music]